voilà on est déjà à la mi-année et les
marchés financiers si on sont bien loin
de refléter l'Apocalypse économique que
certains prévisionnistes nous
annonçaient pour 2023 au début de
l'année on va faire le point ce soir
avec Simon plante gestionnaire de
portefeuille conseiller principal de
gestion de patrimoine à la Financière
Banque Nationale bonsoir Monsieur plante
bonsoir On va d'entrer de jeux pour
mettre la table regardez ce qui s'est
passé avec les principaux indices
boursiers ceux qu'on suit souvent par
exemple SNP 500 le Nasdaq l'évolution de
ces indices là quand on va regarder les
courbes on a en Jones donc le SNP 500
c'est une progression de 16,5% en 6 mois
pour les six premiers mois de l'année le
Nasdaq 40% à peu près quel bilan vous
faites quand vous regardez ces
courbes-là
ventilation on a déjà un indice que on a
eu une période haussière dans le marché
mais ça pas été général ça a été très
niché dans un secteur une certaine
taille donc les titres technologies puis
on parle de très grandes sociétés ou de
méga capitalisation qui ont vraiment été
les coqueluche ou les capitaux ont
migrés si on regarde les chiffres même
de plus près la SNP 500 c'est 500 plus
importantes sociétés inscrite en Bourse
aux États-Unis les 15 plus importants au
niveau de leur taille on progresse en
moyenne de 35%. donc on voit le
rendement similaire à ce que Nasdaq
affiché parce que c'est très
technologique c'est société là puis en
fait 80 85 % du rebond est expliqué par
ces fameux 15 sociétés de société là de
très grande taille bon alors on comprend
que c'est vraiment pas généralisé mais
on comprend que c'est en hausse et de
manière assez soutenue après une année
2022 plutôt pénible pour les
investisseurs là la question qu'on se
pose c'est pourquoi parce que 2023 on a
eu les banques centrales avec des
hausses de taux on a eu un secteur
bancaire qui a frôler la crise aux
États-Unis qu'est-ce qui maintient la
confiance je pense que certains
soulagement de la part des investisseurs
parce que lorsqu'on prenait son cloche
le coût des investisseurs vers la fin de
l'année dernière le pessimiste était
très élevé il faut remonter à la crise
financière de 2008 pour trouver ce genre
de tempérament là de l'investisseur la
prudence était vraiment demain par
contre comme vous l'avez dit on a que
quand même des enjeux au niveau des
banques américaines entre autres un
plafond de la dette à négocier mais
finalement le pire c'est pas matérialisé
puis entre-temps ce qu'on observe c'est
que dans une certaine mesure la médecine
des banques centrales fonctionne parce
qu'on va tranquillement l'inflation BC
on est encore au niveau de 3 et demi
pour cent on est pas au niveau de la
cible de 2% mais on voit un certain
progrès puis finalement l'année dernière
ce qu'on disait certains disaient c'est
que les finalement Jérôme Paol avait
mentionné que l'inflation était
transitoire et on dit que tu es
permanente mais lorsqu'on déballe les
chiffres on peut voir que effectivement
il y avait une portion d'inflation qui
était transitoire donc devant ce
soulagement là les investisseurs ont
commencé à retourner dans le marché vers
certaines thématiques qu'on vient de
parler ouais thématiques techno entre
autres vous le disiez bon dans le
secteur des techno là on pensait par
contre que toutes les grandes
entreprises qui avaient été vraiment la
locomotive des gains au début de la
pandémie on pensait qu'elle finirait par
manquer de carburant là qu'est-ce qui se
passe qu'est-ce qui explique
marché là les investisseurs sont très
prudents donc on n'a pas d'investisseurs
qui embarque dans le secteur parce qu'on
part danser le bateau on a eu des bulles
dans le passé on peut penser au Canada
avec dans le secteur du cannabis avec
les crypto-monnaies et en FT la bulle en
à la au début des années 2000 qui a
éclaté c'est pas le genre de même
comportement puis dans ce bon là qui est
assisté au niveau de la prédictions du
potentiel de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est surtout entre autres la société
Nvidia qui justement elle a vraiment
affiché une croissance de ces ventes
pour le prochain trimestre donc
potentiellement ça peut se justifier ce
genre d'évaluation là si la tendance se
maintient qu'on vient d'observer une
intro dernier mois est-ce qu'on est donc
agressif dans notre positionnement pour
les six prochains mois ou après des
gains importants de 40% pour le Nasdaq
on prend un pas de recul et on est plus
prudent mais je pense que la thématique
qu'on vient d'observer peut-être va
s'essouffler on va atteindre un plateau
peut-être que d'autres catalyses
intéressants ce qui va amener le marché
à croire il y aurait deux facteurs qui
me vient à l'esprit entre autres c'est
les marges de profit qui ont augmenté de
90% j'en doute que ça soit le cas bon on
va suivre ça avec vous pour la fin 2023
merci beaucoup Simon plan merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]